depuis le début de la guerre thierry
vient d'accueillir des réfugiés bon bah
lanka est le principal point d'entrée
pour les ukrainiens venus des grandes
villes du sud
chaque jour ils sont des milliers à
franchir la frontière
face à un tel un flux ce français
installé en moldavie depuis 12 ans dit
vouloir prendre sa part
en fait c'est une famille de sept
personnes ils veulent aller se rejoindre
la pologne mais ils n'ont pas d'argent
il en rien du tout donc
il faut qu'on les prenne
son association offre un toit et de
l'aide à cette famille qui a fait
nikolaïev sous les bombes
trois corps étaient encore dans tintin
à saint ciers de canesse comme ouvrier
s'est associé de cannes à
6h et
ici ils vont se poser quelques jours
prendre des nouvelles des proches restés
au pays
[Musique]
donc convertir
il a vraiment aidé à m
[Musique]
ou pas
dans quelques jours ils reprendront la
route en espérant pouvoir rentrer en
ukraine
une fois la paix retrouvée